so zach please suck on the hill
26 years of age the ball state
alum 6'3 220 pounds facing brandon allow
to start it
great change up by zach policek and that
got loud out on the front
foot lines the first pitch
oh what a catch by ernie clement with
that shift on
playing shallow right field able to go
up and rob him of a hit
and nelson cruz makes his way to the
plate
with minnesota he was hitting 294.
there's a ground ball hitting up the
middle cut off by him and rosario gets
up throws
got him a one two three first inning for
zach please sack and the indians are
coming to bat
for the tampa bay rays it's going to be
left-hander josh fleming making his
eighth start of the season
16th game overall
first pitch skied into right for
rosarina
he's back with the glove up and making
the catch
and he gets a strike on the inside
corner strike call
oh man another really good change up
both of his strikeouts on that pitch
franco with a soft liner into center
there's a base hit
[Applause]
ground ball that's going to go through
off the bat of a rose arena
diaz heads to the plate the throw goes
to third and it pops loose
now franco gets up he's gonna head to
the plate and he is safe
and the ball is loose there and here
comes a rose arena
he's gonna circle him the throwback is
loose on the infield
and the race come up with three runs
how about that well there's the grounder
that gets into center field and then
oscar mercado
off there gets away from jose ramirez
and far enough away that wonder franco's
gonna be aggressive gets off austin
hedges
i'll tell you what this is just flat out
ugly if you're a cleveland indian or a
fan or a coaching
member of the coaching staff
this one oh what a pick up there by
franco and the thriller first
boy a great play quick reactions by the
young infielder franco
put a star by that one
on the ground to third down to the glove
and they
throw in plenty of time can you imagine
having your name attached to those two
hitters
and nelson cruz is third with 220.
he shoots this one into right field with
some carry
that one is going to get out a home run
to right
by nelson cruz his first home run
in a raised uniform his first hit in a
range uniform
number 20 on the year and nelson cruz
gets it down the other way
and a line drive single on the right
field for bet rosario
fernandez stopping at second and the
indians have two on with one out
that's eddie's patented their ahmed's
patented swing right there
this is the situation that they're gonna
have to go at josie here because there's
really not a whole lot of
space to put him anywhere there's the
heater
goodbye jose
ramirez home run number 20. and that
gets the indians back to within a run
and oh my goodness did he smoke that
pitch
one swing of the bat if he brings him
right back into the game
that might have been that cutter he
tried to get inside but that didn't work
boy did he get the barrel hit up yeah he
was waiting for it baby
so they're right back in it with one
swing
good swing by mercado lead off single
here in the fourth
he just reached out punched it the other
way mercano hits the bag he'll hold
right there
[Applause]
and makes the catch no runs a couple
hits two men
left we go to the fifth 4-3 tampa bay
center field mercado again he's got it
and the rays go one two three the rays
do have the lead by one as andrew
kittridge comes on
[Applause]
did he go that pitch running in saying
he
went around to retire the side a one two
three fifth
smash to first what a play by euchang
stayed right with a wicked hop
and a good flip to police shack and
that's eight straight sent down by the
indians right-hander
broken bat single to right field for
yucheng
that's a beautiful thing right there
chang stayed on it
gave up his bat but gotta base hit two
for three tonight now
which popped up into short right
rosarina is there to make the catch
no runs a hit one left we're headed into
the seven
four three half a bag zach sitting fine
84 pitches six innings
he made 12 pitches in the fourth eight
in the fifth
ten in the six just a really strange
second inning
three two and that's lined into right
that's gonna be off the wall bounding on
a couple of hops
reyes plays the karim a double for lau
that is trouble center field on the run
a diving catch by bradley zimmer
for out number two beautiful
nice play and i mean it just caught
right into the palm
look at it almost came out of the glove
when he lands this will be a good shot
watch it hits the ground and it's right
down there wow
he is out looking what a job by nick
salin
come in and strike out nelson cruz
off of whistler and this is going to be
an infield hit for cesar
jose ramirez he smoked one out of here
to the bleachers in left field batting
right-handed in the third
runner goes in richtony field that's a
fair ball off the wall and down goes to
rosa arena
hernandez scores jose is going for third
and he is
saved
that'll be a triple for jose that'll be
his second
triple and we have a new ball game he
tied it up with two outs just a clutch
base hit here so he's driven in all four
for the indians
into the dirt and another stop boy i'll
tell you that's
hit him and hit it wound up and hit him
i'm telling you hedges has been
something back there
trying to block that but it hits
kiermeier
so the rays are going to call upon joey
wendell
and he's shoots it into left center
the rays are going to take the lead by
crosses the plate
zimmer came up with that ball as he
raced over from center toward the gap
joy gets hold of this one sends it deep
to right
reyes runs to the wall it's gone
home run for g-man choice on a 2-0
pitch joy unloads a three-round blast
and the rays make it a four-round ball
game
8-4
[Applause]
and a little check swing on 99
throw down to first and that's going to
do it
the reys have taken this one 10-5